dominic what of reports uh reaching us
from
russian media saying that russia is
ready to send a delegation to the
capital of belarus for talks with
ukraine
yeah there are signs of a diplomatic
track opening um just to pick up on what
laura was saying that the fact that it
has to be said this is an important
symbolic gesture but vladimir putin has
already priced in the possibility of
sanctions against him and his cronies um
an example of that is the fact that he
moved his yacht his 73 million pounds
super yacht that reportedly is his was
moved from the hamburg shipyard where it
was being repaired before those repairs
were finished a week or so ago uh back
to russia and we assume that's because
he was anticipating the possibility of
of these sanctions freezing his assets
of course one of his assets would be uh
that super yacht and putin has made it
very clear to the russians that he's
seen these sanctions coming and he's
saying that russia is prepared for
whatever russia throws the west throws
against it and the fact is that the
threat of these sanctions has not
deterred him from doing what he's doing
now but going back to that diplomatic
track yes the the russians are saying
that um they are going to they're
considering sending a delegation to
minsk the bello russian capital in
response to what vladimir zelinski the
ukrainian president has offered
reportedly which is to discuss the
neutrality of ukraine in return for
peace now what we've heard from the
kremlin spokesman dmitry peskov adds a
pretty important caveat to that which is
that that will only happen if ukraine
accepts the demilitarization and
denarcification
of its country which is effectively
surrender terms so i'll have to see how
the ukrainians react to that but there
is a fledgling hope at least of some
kind of diplomatic way out of uh what is
emerging to be a military campaign that
takes us back to world war ii in ukraine